speaking of did you see the five bit the
big five night late night hosts Strike
Force Five dude they're doing a Twitter
show together and it looks so lame
Seth uh what's his name Seth something
Myers Myers looked so miserable in that
promo it's like you couldn't even say it
with feeling I saw the clip and now I
have to start chemoing okay
it's got Jimmy and Jimmy Fallon looks so
annoyed with Jimmy Kimmel like those
guys do not want to be in the same room
together he's like oh my God I'm stuck
up they're getting paid 100 million
bucks a night or whatever contract and
the studios were like you're doing we
know how to make money and generate
contact while they're content while
there's no writers you're doing this
dude they made Stephen Colbert be like
the ringleader and the other guy's like
who is this dip like I'm not bowing down
to this guy why is he the one ring
leading this crap it's really annoying
I I think it's it's breaking about
breaking apart